[موسيقى]
موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم التهمه الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه الرئيس الروسيه بعدم الرغبه في
التفاوض وقالت ان عليه العوده الى الواقع
وكان رئيس الروسي وقد قال ان بلاده على
استعداد للاتفاق على حلول مقبوله مع جميع
شركاء لتسويه النزاع في اوكرانيا
برفض الجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات
وقال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي ان
العالم سيستمر
كارثه نوويه اذا لم يتم توفير ضمانه
الامنيه لروسيا مشددا على ان بلاده ستبذل
قصار جهدها لمنع حدوث ذلك
قالت الخارجيه صينيه ان العلاقات مع
الولايات المتحده تواجه تحديات خطيره بسبب
ما وصفته بعناد واشنطن على رؤيه بيجينك
منافس الرئيس بدوره اعلن الجيش الصيني
تنظيم تدريبات هجوميه بحريه وجويه حول
جزيره تايوان واعتبر المناورات ردا حازما
على ما وصفه بالتصعيد والاستفزاز الامريكي
التايواني
كذلك بعد اقرار الكونغرس الامريكي قانون
الموازنه للعام المالي المقبل الذي يسمح
بتقديم مساعدات العسكريه الفوريه
الى 10 مليارات دولار
في سودان اعلن مجلس السياده عزمه فرض
السلم في ولايه جنوب دارفور بنشر تعزيزات
عسكريه لتامين القرى المتاخره بالاشتباكات
بموجب اتفاق جوبا بدوره اعلن اوالي جنوب
دارفور حاله الطوارئ بالولايه وحظره اجوال
داخل منطقه بليله وكانت مصادر محليه قد
اعلنت مقتل احد عشر شخصا واصابه نحو 20 في
اشتباكات دارت خلال الايام الماضيه
بالولايه كما اعلن مسؤولون محليون نزوحا
25000 شخص وطالب بفتح ممرات امنه نحو
المخيمات
سجل
شرقيه الصين مليون اصابه يوميا بفايروس
كورونا وسط توقعات بانتشار الفايروس
بوتيره غير مسبوقه في البلاد واعلنت لجنه
الصحه الصينيه انها لن تنشر البيانات
اليوميه لاصابات ووفيات كورونا اعتبارا من
امس جاء ذلك بعد تزايد المخاوف بشان نقص
المعلومات منذ ان اجرد بيجين تغييرات
شامله على سياسه صفر كوفيلد
افاد حاكم ولايه نيورك الامريكيه بارتفاع
عدد قتلى العاصمه الثلجيه التي تضرب
الولايه الى اثني عشر شخصا وكانت وسائل
الاعلام في الولايه قد افادت بارتفاع قتل
العاصفه في مدينه بافلو الى سبعه اشخاص
بعد العثور على اربع جثث متجمده في
السيارات صباح امس وذكر شبكه بافلو نيوز
المحليه ان عدد القتلى في المدينه المرشح
للارتفاع مع استمرار عمليات البحث
والانقاذ
وفي ولايه تكساس اعلنت وزاره الطاقه حاله
الطوارئ مشيره الى نقص الكهرباء بعد ان
تسبب سوء الاحوال الجويه في توقف محطه
التوليد وقالت وزاره الطاقه ان 11,000
ميغاوات من محطات الكهرباء التي تعمل
بالفحم والغاز والطاقه الشمسيه انقطعت او
انخفضت بسبب الظروف الجويه
نهايه الموجز الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]